hi I'm Rio frederica I'm a presenter and  so learn how to create this quick and  easy French braid look make sure you  keep watching so to start with I use a  conditioner  it makes the ends all smooth so at the  bottom of the braid it looks lovely you  brush your hair through to make sure  it's free of knots I then split it down  the side parting so you've got a nice  straight parting from front to back  and then put one section in a hair  bubble to keep it out of my way as I  start with a braid at the beginning and  then each time I braid I attach another  bit of hair so hair that's free  [Music]  until I get to the end I'd then repeat  that on the next side once it's done I  put two hair bands at the bottom of each  braid and then I finish it off with  hairspray for more videos like this make  sure you subscribe to glamour UK's  YouTube channel